on our railways
in our courts
examples
and ports
as the cost of living bites industrial
action looms we didn't mean to do this
you know i mean it happened we can't
afford living
london bus drivers the latest to walk
out
what would be a good deal for you
anything above inflation that's what we
want we want to afford living
i live by myself so paying the bills and
everything is not enough my pay has only
gone up five pounds in 16 years
so imagine that how much my rent got up
my food my cost of living in general
with every strike comes disruption
strike yeah i didn't know yesterday they
were working oh my god i need to go by
awakening
late buses missed appointments slack is
not good enough
in scotland overflowing bins
and now the uk's two biggest unions are
proposing coordinated action we would
encourage unions to
uh you know where workers have took that
really difficult decision to take
industrial action we want it to be
as sharp and as effective as it can be
in order for it not to be prolonged then
you want to maximize its effectiveness
if that means unions working together
then we would absolutely support and
encourage unions to do that
coordinated action would stop short of a
general strike which is what some union
leaders want to see the problem for the
government is raising pay could fuel
inflation further the next prime
minister is taking over at an
extraordinary time grappling of course
with how to help people with rising
energy bills but dealing too with this
row over public sector pay that could
see everyone from bus drivers to civil
servants to barristers to nurses on
picket lines and that will make the
business of day-to-day government
getting things done very difficult
liz trust and rishi sunak say they're
ready for a fight with the unions and
today the government said they're
disappointed by what they call more
unnecessary disruption to people's lives
the next prime minister will have their
work cut out there to stop a winter of
industrial unrest ali fortescue sky news